[موسيقى]
حكم المونديال ساخن في البطاقات الحمراء
ورامريز يودع الملاعب من مروحيه ولايبزيغ
يبكي بسبب مانشستر سيتي هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
يبدو ان التعامل مع الحكم فكوندو تيو لن
يكون سهلا في مونديال قطر فقد اشهر خلال
لقاء السوبر الارجنتيني بين البوكا
جونيورز وريستنج بالامس خلال مباراه في
الكاس 10 بطاقات حمراء سبع منها في شجار
بعد الهدف القاتل لكارلوس الكراس لصالح
رزق ويشارك طيور ضمن طاقم من تحكيمي مكون
من سبعه حكام من امريكا الجنوبيه في كاس
العالم المقبله ماذا ينتظر اللاعبين
في طياره مروحيه وصل اللاعب البرازيلي
رامي ريز الى ملعب مباراه اعتزاله رسميا
لعلم مستديره بعد مسيره دامت 15 عاما في
الملاعب وكان في استقبال لاعب انديه
بنفيكا و تشيلسي وبالميراس الساحر
رونالدينهو والذي شارك في المباراه الحدث
مع البلوز بهدفه الشهير الذي احرزه في
شباك برشلونه في نصف نهائي دوري ابطال
اوروبا
بعدما وضعته قرعه دوري ابطال اوروبا في
وجه مانشستر سيتي الانجليزي نشر حساب نادي
لايف زيك الالماني تغريده وفيها وجه باكن
فقط تعبيرا عن صعوبه المواجهه قبل ان يعود
ادمن الحساب وتذكر انا لابسك تغلب على
السيتي في ديسمبر من العام واحد و20
بهدفين مقابل هدف في دور المجموعات من
دوري ابطال اوروبا
ستشهد النسخه الحاليه من المونديال توفير
خدمات الوصف الصوتيه للمكفوفين وضعاف
البصر في حفل الافتتاح حيث من المقرر ان
يشارك اربعه معلقين من طلاب وخريجي برنامج
ماجستير الاداب في الترجمه السمعيه
والبصريه في عمليه الترجمه في حين سيشارك
19 معلقا في تقديم هذه الخدمه خلال باقي
المباريات
[موسيقى]